bonjour bienvenue sur 9 7 4 tv
aujourd'hui on va parler de nutrition et
à ce titre nous revenons sur ce plateau
sully adrian chargé de projet
restauration scolaire à la direction
éducation bonjour bonjour
elodie filin chargé de gestion de
projets agro nutrition direction de
l'agriculture
bonjour et frédéric mas des
diététiciennes chargée de projet donc en
termes de nutrition aujourd'hui on se
focalise un petit peu sur l'opération 5
sur 5
donc c'est les journées cinq sur scène
plus précisément avec notamment nos
directions et d'autres partenaires
donc il s'agit de mieux d'amener les
jeunes à mieux manger au sein
d'établissements les établissements
scolaires et plus particulièrement des
collèges donc ça se passe ça sera du
comment concrètement sur le terrain
alors les journées cinq sur cinq c'est
une action qui est menée par nous
l'ireps il s'agit d'une charte qui
propose aux établissements scolaires
volontaires de mettre en place des
actions pour promouvoir la promotion des
fruits et légumes locaux
donc ça se traduit par trois objectifs
donc c'est de communiquer sur les fruits
et légumes locaux
c'est aussi mettre au niveau de la
restauration scolaire des fruits et
légumes locaux lors de ces journées 5
sur 5 500 jeux sachant qu'il y en a cinq
dans l'année scolaire et au pays de
mettre en place des actions sur ses
journées sur la promotion des fruits et
légumes locaux donc ça peut se traduire
sous forme d'ateliers à l'éducation
précisément c'est quoi un petit peu le
rôle du conseil général dans ce genre
d'opération et plus globalement dans
dans la citation à mieux manger pour les
pour nos jeunes collégiens alors
globalement la direction de l'éducation
accompagne les collèges sur la mise en
oeuvre de leur mission de restauration
donc c'est un accompagnement concernant
le fonctionnement l'organisation les
équipements
notamment l'assistance technique les
formations en termes d'hygiène et qui
parlent plus particulièrement récemment
nous avons mis en place une formation
concernant l'application de la nouvelle
réglementation nutrition à savoir
l'application de l'arrêté du 30
septembre 2011 concernant l'équilibré
nutritionnel des repas servis aux
enfants
alors concernant cette augmentation les
trois grands principes je dirais ses
limites et les plats de la consommation
des plats trop gras trop sucré augmenter
la consommation des fruits et légumes et
augmenter la consommation des produits
laitiers à savoir un produit laitier
obligatoire à chaque repas pas
réellement à salou menons des actions de
valorisation des produits locaux en
colorant collaboration bien sûr avec nos
collègues de la direction de
l'agriculture
il sut présent et donc au niveau de
l'agriculture c'est aussi cesser cette
pratique c'est aussi de d'inciter les
jeunes à manger peut-être plus de
produits péi plus de produits
réunionnais et les réconcilier avec avec
ce que mangent les réunionnais depuis
très longtemps à savoir peut-être des
produits plus de base comme le riz le
grain ou de caries c'est aussi ça les
légumes lontan
on va dire que la réunion a les atours
terme
de produits agricoles donc nous conseil
général nous avons comme objectif de
valoriser justement cette production
locale et les collèges vous présente un
un mot marché un bon volume pour pour
écouler ses produits
donc notre but c'est de faciliter
l'intégration de des produits agricoles
locaux dans nos établissements scolaires
notamment par le biais d'actions
ponctuelles qu'on mène régulièrement
dans les collèges nous avons des repas
thématiques comme les les légumes lontan
où il ya eu une intervention du cirad et
là ça permet justement de faire
découvrir de sensibiliser les élèves par
rapport à notre production locale alors
viens petit coup sur ce que vient de
dire par rapport à manger moins gras est
ce que ça veut dire que bad rougail
saucisses malonga et boucané ou du moins
peut-être cuisiner autrement en
concrètement ça ça serait quoi de manger
moins gras alors pas du tout il ne
s'agit pas non plus de ne pas consommer
les plats créoles guillemets j'ai tiré
leurs gaz ceci c'est toujours autorisées
mais limitées en gérant fréquent en
fréquence de plats le carré volaille le
cari poulet toujours autorisé la s'est
pas limitée et l'a donc la diététicienne
est totalement en accord avec cela je
suppose et c'est vraiment est-ce que à
la réunion les bons élèves
est-ce que ça se passe bien est ce qu'il
faut vraiment rééduquer ou alors
globalement ça se passe plutôt bien
alors en termes d'alimentation
l'alimentation déjà réunionnaise est
l'équilibré on a trié grain caries je
pense que ce sur quoi il faut faire
attention ça va être vraiment content
que vivent les quantités de duy les
quantités de graisses les quantités de
sucre aussi et puis limité les produits
gras voilà que monsieur adrien 10 et
limiter les produits gras comme les
chats recrute cutri donc ça va être
saucisses boucané boudin et donc c'est
vrai que ce genre de produire là on
conseille par exemple une fois par
semaine donc
alors qu'on a tendance à en consommer
quand même beaucoup plus
régulièrement et donc à cette
alimentation réunionnaise on a aussi les
brèdes les fruits et des légumes
donc on peut rajouter aussi les produits
laitiers et c'est l'excès peut-être de
produits sucrés de produits gras qui
fait que ça peut déséquilibrer
l'alimentation des personnes alors que
globalement dont j'ai payé manger dépôts
du pays est ce que ça vaut bien plus
cher pour l'épreuve à manger et payer
non sens revient pas ça revient pas
globalement plus cher d'autant plus que
en respectant les saisons on a forcément
à ce moment là des produits moins chers
de qualité et locaux très bien passé sur
ses conseils que se termine notre
émission merci à nos invités et attribue
un personnage